[Music]
this is dave klein reading for kevin
kenizevic
the legend of zelda's skyward sword is
one of the most divisive entries in
nintendo's acclaimed series
as the first full-fledged zelda game
designed for the wii
the title made extensive use of the wii
remote as showing the series traditional
control scheme
for controversial motion controls a
decade later
nintendo has remastered skyward's sword
for the switch and while many of the
game's original faults remain intact a
variety of welcome tweaks make it easier
to appreciate now
as with the wii u remasters of the wind
waker and twilight princess
nintendo has made numerous quality of
life improvements to skyward sword
that are largely minor tweaks but have
an appreciable effect on the game's
playability
some previously mandatory tutorials are
now optional
for instance and you can speed up
dialogue and skip cutscenes making the
game's
languid opening moments much breezier
more substantial are the adjustments to
phi the spirit who dwells within your
sword
like navi and midna in previous zelda
games phi
serves as your companion for most of the
adventure and skyward sword
frequently interjecting to relay story
information and other hints
her constant interruptions made her one
of the most
grating aspects of the original game
especially as the
insights she offered were often
glaringly
obvious that has largely been rectified
here
and while she still speaks frequently in
skyward sword hd
much of her dialogue is now optional
which makes her less bothersome and
improves the game's overall pacing
the biggest change in skyward sword hd
however is the addition of button only
controls
this new control scheme can be toggled
on or off at any point from the options
menu and allows you to play the game
without motion controls
unfortunately it doesn't work that well
because so many aspects of the game were
designed around the increased range of
movements
that motion controls afforded the button
controls feel like a cumbersome
workaround most of the actions you would
normally perform
using gestures have been mapped to the
right stick which means the button only
scheme is dramatically
different from the controls in other
zelda games rather than
swinging your sword with the press of a
button for instance slashes are
performed by flicking the right stick in
different directions
and you need to hold the right stick
forward and press the zr button to throw
a bomb overhead
as a result even simple actions feel
more convoluted to execute
the camera also becomes more cumbersome
to control while using the button only
scheme
when motion controls are enabled you can
freely adjust the camera using the right
stick a marked improvement over the
original game as the wii
lac dual analog sticks however because
the button only scheme maps link's sword
arm to the right stick
you need to hold the l button down in
order to swing the camera on with said
stick
or rely on pressing the zl button to
constantly recenter the camera behind
link the old-fashioned way
it isn't nearly as intuitive and you'll
frequently find yourself inadvertently
slashing with your sword when you intend
to rotate the camera
[Music]
that's not to say the button only
controls are entirely worse however
some items and actions actually benefit
from the new control scheme
maneuvering the beetle and insect shaped
drone that you acquire early on in the
adventure
is handled via the left stick rather
than by turning the joy-con
making it easier to pilot with button
controls swimming underwater
similarly works better as you maneuver
link with the left stick rather than by
moving the joy-con
on the whole however the button-only
controls don't feel nearly as natural to
use
and they're a less than ideal
alternative to the motion controls
fortunately the motion controls largely
function well
whether or not they're improved over the
original game as nintendo has claimed in
trailers
is debatable i couldn't personally
notice an appreciable difference from my
time with the game
that said the motion controls are
responsive and i never encountered any
significant issues when performing
link's actions
slashing with the sword by swinging the
joy-con feels intuitive
and fun and aiming with the controller's
gyroscope is much snappier than with the
control stick
you will however need to frequently
reset the pointer while you play
something i don't recall ever having an
issue with in the original game
fortunately that can be done quickly and
easily with the press of the y button
so never becomes a significant problem
these nips
and tucks help smooth over skyward
sword's rougher edges and improve the
overall experience
but the core game is fundamentally
unchanged
which means its original faults remain
intact
more than other zelda games skyward
swords suffered from bloat and that
holds true in this remaster
there are many moments in the story
where you'll be asked to revisit a
previous area in order to retrieve a
particular item
or perform some other task before you
can progress and these always feel like
busy work meant to prolong your
adventure worse are the tear hunts which
require you to collect
15 sacred tears while avoiding
invincible foes that can take you out in
one strike
should one of these enemies catch you
you'll need to restart the
entire trial from the beginning and
re-obtain any tiers you had previously
collected
this steep penalty makes these tasks
much more frustrating than the tear
hunts and twilight princess
and they would have been more bearable
had nintendo reduced the number of tiers
you had to collect
as it did in twilight princess hd
unfortunately skyward swords tear hunts
are unchanged and they're
among the worst aspects of the game
despite these flaws skyward sword is
also filled with many
genuinely magical moments this
soundtrack
notable for being zelda's first fully
orchestrated score
is still delightful
[Music]
and the story is one of the most
touching tales the series has ever woven
shedding light on the origins of hyrule
and other elements that become
hallmarks of the franchise the game's
dungeons are a highlight as well
filled with clever puzzles that test
your observation and lateral thinking
after breath of the wild excise classic
style dungeons
skyward swords feel especially fresh and
satisfying to explore
and the boss battles that await within
are among the most fun encounters in the
series
[Music]
[Music]
these elements outweigh the game's flaws
and make it a worthwhile adventure
the various quality of life tweaks that
nintendo's implemented here
welcome as they are don't fix skyward
sword's biggest
issues and it remains the most uneven 3d
entry into the zelda series
even so the improvements in the switch
remaster make the overall experience
more enjoyable
and the characteristic zelda magic
ultimately outshines the game's faults
[Music]